All right,
welcome back to computer vision.
We're going to continue introducing
particle filters for tracking.
I also want to say thank you I
think it's Sebastian Thrun and,
and/or Dieter Fox or somebody else
who's done a bunch of slides that have
actually lost their, their authorship
is lost to all of humanity.
Because if you take a look
at particle filtering,
you'll see these same
pictures everywhere.
So whoever did them, thanks.
All right, so you remember I hope,
that the reason we're doing all this is
because unlike Kalman filter where we
were going to represent the densities to
where things are, are the nice Gaussian.
The idea is we might want to
have an arbitrary density.
And graphically, this,
that's what's shown here,
the idea of propagating
a density through time.
Now, the basic idea that we're
going to make use of is instead of
having some sort of analytic
representation of our densities,
we're going to have
these set of particles.
We've talked before about how
the distribution in terms of
where the particles are and
perhaps the weight of the particles.
That's what we're going to
substitute for the density.
Right?
And our goal is, so
that as we're doing this tracking,
eventually we have a set of particles
such that the probability that you get
a particle at some particular place
is essentially the probability
that the state is actually at that place
having observed all the observations.
And the way we do this is we're
going to do this as a Bayes filter.
We introduced this last time,
where we said that basically you
take your prediction from before.
And the way you get to
your prediction is,
you take your previous belief of all
the different places you might be.
And talk about the probability that you
could end up at some given xt, you some
that all up, and that's your prior
belief that you could be at xt.
You take your measurement,
you multiply it by your likelihood and
because of Bayes rules which does the,
the swapping of the variables,
that gives us our new belief about xt.
So we're going to take particles and
we're going to define a Bayes
filter using those particles.